[Music]
there were our favorite Disney stars
when we were young but what have they
been up to now you'll be happy to hear
that your first celebrity crush is now
more handsome than ever stay tuned until
the end to see how much Cameron boys
changed over the years
if you love Disney stars as much as we
do don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel please give this video a big
thumbs up today we are showing you
Disney famous boy stars in real life
Zac Efron in 2006 you know it keep
themselves from falling in love with
this new Disney star in high school
musical Troy Bolton had everything we
could ever wish for in a boy who is
handsome nice and talented and things
just got better when we realized that
Jack Efron was just like that in real
life
unfortunately this sweetheart was
already in love with Vanessa Hudgens
both in the movie and in real life so we
didn't have any chances with him but
that didn't keep us from dreaming we had
the chance to see the actor on the big
screen until High School Musical 3
senior year in 2008 since he left the
Disney Channel he's been working on many
movies like 17 again neighbours and
Baywatch and through the years we just
couldn't keep our eyes off of him is it
us or did he become even more
good-looking in every movie our first
celebrity crush who used to be a cute
boy next door turned out to be a really
muscular man and everyone had the chance
to appreciate it when Rita Ora ripped
his shirt off his test at the MTV Movie
Awards live on TV in 2014 this young
actor didn't stop being popular
since the beginning of his career and we
think that his pretty face is not going
anywhere
he just proved things just keep getting
better with time
Jake TOS we first saw the young actor on
Disney Channel in the movie johnny
kapahala back on board in 2007 but it
was in 2009 that he really got the
chance to shine in Wizards of Waverly
Place until 2012 as the youngest of the
russo kids max Russo was like a little
brother to us he was the most
mischievous Wizard determined to take
his magic to the max even though he
sometimes looks a little bit stupid we
cannot say that a lot of people had a
crush on JT Austin at that time he was
just Alex's sibling after all but you
will probably regret thinking this
because he looks better than ever now
that he is a grown-up as we can see he
probably used all his magic powers to
turn himself into a really handsome man
but unfortunately you won't get the
chance to see these ABS a lot that's
because JT Austin is now mostly working
as a voice actor he used to be the voice
of Diego in Dora the Explorer and go
Diego go from 2005 to 2009 before
working for Disney and now you can hear
his voice in movies and TV shows like
Rio Justice League action and the emoji
movie but don't worry Jake is still
interested a working as an actor so
you'll probably get the chance to watch
him on the big screen very soon Nick
Jonas
in 2008 the Jonas Brothers were probably
the most popular boy bands in the world
Nick Jonas with most teenagers favorite
singer and people from all around the
world were just obsessed with his good
looks
beautiful voice that's why we were
really happy to see him in the TV movie
Camp Rock but he didn't get all the
attention that he deserved until he was
the hero of his own TV series Jonas from
2009 to 2010 the show didn't last for a
very long time but it was still enough
for us to appreciate the look of this
talented singer unfortunately the boy
band split up in 2013 and the three
brothers decided to work separately Nick
is actually the one who brought it to
the table saying that he wanted to focus
on different things like acting and
doing music on his own we think that
this was the best decision for Nick
Jonas being a little less popular is
probably a little less stressful but
people still love him just as much
his song jealous proved to the whole
world that the singer could still be
great on his own his music videos are
still being watched by millions of
people nowadays so we believe that he is
still on the road to success with this
new body you worked hard for we could
say that the singer now has everything
we could ever wish for
and even more Joe Jonas Nick is not the
only Jonas brother who has been really
successful since he worked for the
Disney Channel we should not forget that
Joe Jonas was actually one of the main
characters in camp Rock
he was so good that Demi Lovato couldn't
keep herself from falling in love with
him we admit that we would have done the
same
we were her she then started working on
Jonas with his three brothers from 2009
to 2010
and we had the chance to see him as one
of the main characters one last time in
Camp Rock to the final champ
we already know that the boy band split
up in 2013 they all knew that things
were getting more complicated and they
decided that the best way to support
each other was to stop working together
but was it the best decision for this
brother the singer is now working with a
new pop rock troupe dnce we all had the
song cake by the ocean stuck in our
heads so we know that they have the
potential to become really popular
however it wasn't easy at first to
perform in front of only 50 people when
Joe is used to having thousands of fans
in front of him but no matter what Joe
Jonas knows what he wants and how to get
it that's all he needs to be successful
Ross Lynch we had the chance to watch
this actor in Austin and Ally in 2011
until the TV series ended in 2016
Austin moon was a singer and dancer who
became an overnight internet sensation
after uploading a video online it would
have been great if he didn't steal the
song from Ally
but after apologizing to her they
finally decided to become music partners
we would have done the same thing his
gorgeous blonde hair is such a beautiful
distractions that it would be hard
luckily for us Roslin's just got even
better over the years on the show he
started out as a cute young teenager and
by the end of the TV series he was a
grown-up man no one could resist if you
don't believe us just look at pictures
of him when he is not wearing a shirt
and you'll quickly understand why this
young man has been working hard on his
body so it deserves a lot of attention
if you want to see what he's been up to
Ross Lynch is now working as an actor on
different projects like the movies my
friend Dahmer and status update we
artist left the Disney Channel only
really recently we already miss him we
can't wait to see what he has been up to
Corbin Bleu this actor was probably one
of the most underestimated members of
the cast of High School Musical sure it
was hard to compete with Zac Efron but
that doesn't mean that Chad Danforth
didn't deserve our attention as the
co-captain of the basketball team
and best friends with Troy Bolton this
character knew that staying together was
the most important thing that's why he
used to be against Troy's singing things
until he realized that his friends could
have the best of both worlds so we think
that caring so much about your friends
is really sweet we last time on Disney
Channel in
School Musical 3 senior year and his
small role in Canada Montana but what
has he been up to now
Corbin Bleu never stopped working as we
have the chance to see him in movies and
TV series like freestyle the beautiful
life TBL One Life to Live and nurse 3d
we also got the chance to see among some
Broadway musicals Zac Efron even decided
to come to one of his shows holiday in
musical and gave him a standing ovation
in the middle of the play blue said that
it was really awesome to see his friend
standing up just because he is a little
further from the spotlight doesn't mean
that he is not doing well Corbin Bleu is
now a better artist than he has ever
been dylan sprouse we first got the
chance to watch the actor on Disney
Channel in The Suite Life of Zack and
Cody
in 2005 he and his brother Kolb were
little troublemakers who lived in a
hotel and turned it into a playground
and just when we couldn't get enough of
them they decided to move out of this
place
to live on a boat in the suite life on
deck from 2008 to 2011 the twins were
ready for even more crazy adventures and
we could wait for the next weird thing
that they were going to do it was great
to see two stars in the show and it was
even better to see that we weren't able
to differentiate them but unfortunately
that was the last we saw of dylan
sprouse not only on the Disney Channel
but on any screen from 2012 2016 the
actors didn't work on any project during
this time he attended college at New
York University Dylan said that he was
just waiting for the right role to come
along and he wanted to do some
human it was in 2017 that he finally
returned to acting in a horror film
called dismissed and the short film
parts lung it's great to see him back on
the big screen because the actor who
used to be a cute kid a so more handsome
than ever we can't wait to see what he
can do in a role that really inspires
him Cole Sprouse we couldn't talk about
Dylan without talking about his twin
brother Cole sprouts the two worked
together on the suite life of zack &
cody until they moved on to the suite
life on deck it was hard to tell who was
our favorite because the two boys were
too similar but there were actually some
differences in 2009 dylan swept his
bangs to the right and cold wet the
bangs to the left
paul was also just a little bit taller
than his brother Dylan but the more they
grew up the more we could see a
difference Cole got a degree in
archaeology while Dylan studied video
game design their hair is also really
different in 2017 as Cole dyed his hair
dark and Dylan now has long blonde hair
but what has Cole been doing now that he
can't work with an identical twin after
taking a break for several years to go
to college you have probably seen the
actor back in high school in Riverdale
in the role of Jughead anyone who
thought that Cole was just a little
troublemaker finally got the chance to
see him as a grown up man with a unique
style that looks great on him even Betty
Cooper couldn't resist him on screen and
in real life because Cole Sprouse and
Lilly Reinhardt are now dating we have
to admit that we are a little jealous
David Henry if we had magic powers we
would use it to create a handsome young
just like him and that's exactly what
happened in Wizards of Waverly Place in
2007 Disney made our dream come to life
by giving the opportunity to this actor
to create this awesome character he was
the oldest brother of the main character
Alex Russo but this time that was not a
good enough reason not to have a crush
on him he was not only good-looking but
he was also one of the most gifted
Wizarding students of recent time we
were not surprised to see many girls
falling in love with him and every time
they broke up we wish to magically
appear on the show to be the next one
unfortunately the show ended in 2012
before we got the chance to be Justin
Rico's girlfriend or boyfriend but that
doesn't mean that we will stop seeing
him anytime soon David Henry is working
on new projects every year including How
I Met Your Mother
we drink that it won't be too long until
he becomes the hero of another popular
TV series and until then we will just
get lost in his gorgeous blue eyes and
we think that they look even better when
he takes his shirt off David Henry never
stopped being a wizard it must be magic
Cameron voice he might be one of the
youngest Disney stars on our list but we
still think that this talented artist
has a lot of potential even Disney can
never get enough of him we first saw
Cameron voice as Luke Ross in Jessie
from 2011 to 2015 he also had the chance
to play Connor in gamers guide to pretty
much everything from 2016 to 2017 we
loved him so much that he also appeared
in good luck charlie shake it up Austin
and Ally
Liv and Maddie and bunk on the Disney
Channel but what we loved the most was
seeing him play the role of a bad boy as
Carlos in descendants in 2015 followed
by the TV movie descendants - in 2017 it
was great to see him play a character
that was really different from him but
who ended up being just as nice at the
end the actor is so popular that it is
probably not the last time that we see
him working for Disney but he changed a
lot over the years not only is he
becoming a better actor in every movie
but we think that he might become a
celebrity crush for many teenagers the
cute little nugget was transformed into
a handsome young man is there any other
famous star that you would like to see
in real life don't be shy to tell us who
it is in the comments section down below
we love to know what you think and
that's it forgive me famous boy stars in
real
for more stories like this make sure you
watch 10 Jessie's dark secret
Disney tried to hide thanks for watching
[Music]